I'm here with Stuart Frye,
who's the Vice President
of Content here at Udacity.
Stuart, thank you so much for
talking to us today.
>> Absolutely.
>> So Stuart's going to
talk to us a bit about the business
side of educational technology.
I know many people are interested in
seeing if they can develop something
they could spin off into a startup.
Also Stuart, for any of our students who
are interested in going into the startup
world or into the ed tech world,
on the business side of things,
what should they know about what
it's like to work in this space?
>> I think it's,
one of the most interesting and
exciting places to start a new business
or launch an innovation right now, but
it's also a very complex place
to think about, as a market.
Education's one of the places where you
have multiple users and your end user is
not always the person who is making the
purchase decisions about the product.
So if we think about the spectrum
of education from preschool up to
higher ed.
You have parents, you have teachers, you
have students, you have administrators,
and the different products that
are being launched across K-12 and
higher ed are targeted in some
way at a mix of those people.
And identifying who are your end users,
who are your gatekeepers,
and who are making the ultimate purchase
decisions can be one of the most complex
set of decisions you make about your
business model, as well as the features
and functionality you're going to
design the product around.
>> Yeah, and I agree completely.
I think that, especially as an educator
myself, I'll always think about
the student as my consumer, but that's
not the person you end up selling to.
That's the person that
ends up using your tool- [CROSSTALK]
>> Right.
>> And oftentimes what they would think
about your tool is not the ultimate
issue, learning can be frustrating.
>> Yep.
>> It's the only domain I know of where
frustrating your end user can sometimes
actually be part of the goal.
>> Yep, absolutely.
>> So I know that some of our
students have project ideas already,
some of them are probably looking for
ideas.
They know,
they want to go into this space, but
they don't know exactly what to do.
So are there any open issues,
open problems that you think
would be worth tackling?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think as you
think about problems to solve
in the education space,
I think your solutions are going to
fall into a couple of categories.
One is a content category, so,
that's where Udacity plays, right?
We are creating content that
we're making available as part of
an online Master's degree program or
as part of our nano degree programs.
In addition to content, there are tools.
So tools either for students,
maybe it makes students more productive,
a better way to take notes,
develop projects, tools for
teachers, a better way to discover new
content, track data, analyze students.
And I think between content and
tools, you need to think about which
area your solution lies best in.
Also, always encourage
entrepreneurs to think about
a problem you've faced immediately.
So, if you haven't spent any time
in a classroom as an educator,
you might think about tackling
a problem that students face,
because you have spent
time as a student.
On the other hand David, you've spent
a ton of time as an educator and
you probably have a long list of
problems that you'd like solved.
So I would start there when you think
about coming up with a solution or
a business idea.
>> Yeah, makes sense, I think in
some ways when you're designing for
yourself as a customer.
It's a good place to start,
although you never want to design
your entire project that way,
because you don't want to design
something that's great for you, but
doesn't work for anybody else.
>> Right and I think that emphasizes
the importance of user testing.
At the very earliest stages,
I mean any ed tech idea that you
have should start as wire frames,
pencil sketches, balsamic, mock ups
that you get out in front of people.
See how they react.
Test an idea very early and
often rather than, to your point,
designing an end solution that works
perfectly for you as an individual, but
doesn't have product
market fit more broadly.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
So let's say it's the end of
the semester, a day after the final
project is due and now students
are wondering, what do I do next?
What do you think the first step that
they should take when the semester's
over, to maybe scale their project up
and do a business or startup should be?
>> Oh wow, yeah so,
this gets back to user testing.
I would identify 20 people that could
be the end user of your product,
and go out and
get some version of it in their hands.
And when I say a version of it,
I do mean it could be a wire frame,
it could be a mock up,
it could be a prototype in Photoshop, or
you could have written some code and
built out a very simple working version.
But step one is to get it out in front
of people, because I guarantee you,
your solution will change and
evolve over time.
And the more quickly you can get
input beyond your own, the better.
And finding those people to test
with isn't always easy, but
I think within the context you have,
I mean you're on a university or
you're surrounded by a community
of students, at least.
Virtually you can find
a lot of people quickly.
>> Yeah, I think that because
we're in this community and
because I think a lot of the projects
that our students develop will
actually be targeted at the OS program,
because it's what they experience.
You've got 3,000 people sitting around,
experiencing the same thing that you're
experiencing, who might be
willing to test it out.
>> Yep, absolutely.
>> I can also share that for
the NSF iCore project,
which seeks to turn academic
research into real world businesses,
one of the first things they ask
all their participants to do is
find 100 customers in one month, and
talk to all of them for half an hour.
>> Wow,
do they have to be paying customers?
>> I don't think, no,
not paying customers yet, but
100 potential customers.
>> Okay.
>> So for this it would be,
talk to 100 parents, students, teachers,
principals, get the the full
range of perspectives on that.
>> Okay.
>> And
they really value that
side of things as well.
>> Awesome.
>> Anything last to share with our
student about working in this field?
>> I think we often say that,
there are two big fields that have yet
to be disrupted by technology,
education, and healthcare.
Two pretty important ones, right?
I would say that disruption is a word
that's often overused and misused.
But when you boil down some of
the key tenets that Clay Christensen
talks about when it comes
to disruptive technologies.
One of those tenets that I
personally find most exciting,
I think offers the most promise
to powerful solutions in
education technology is non consumption.
If you think about the fact that,
in the United States,
only one in three adults
has a four year degree.
And internationally, only about 7% of
people end up with an advanced degree.
The number of people,
that the things you build, could impact.
If you go over and after those
people who are least well served by
the existing system today, the non
consumer of quality education today,
people who can't benefit from
the system as it's built.
That's a huge number of people and
it's a massive impact.
So look for those non consumers,
look for those opportunities to
help people who aren't being helped
today and you'll build great products.
>> That sounds like
part of the foundation,
part of the philosophy behind this
program in general is finding people who
may not be the underserved people
in some remote countries, but
people who currently can't access
quality higher education based
on geographic, or family, or-
>> Economic.
>> Yeah, exactly, constraints.
>> Yep.
>> Great.
Thank you so much for
talking to us today.
>> Absolutely, thanks for having me,
hope anything I said is helpful and
I hope you build amazing things,
good luck.
>> Thanks.